hi everyone welcome to another episode
of
science and technology q a for kids and
others
um i'm probably not as perky as i might
be today i
got my second vaccine dose yesterday
i thought i was doing just fine but i
the last
hour or so i've been decaying a bit
although because i'm a data oriented
person i've been
wearing some continuous temperature
measuring thing so i know that i don't
have a fever yet
at least um
so anyway easy questions for today he
says
famous last words so i notice a question
here from
scott about what are some of the
implications of
my new kind of science for medicine
i suppose that would be a a pertinent
thing to talk about here
you know it's an interesting question
what
uh when we look at medicine there's sort
of
the question of for example can we
predict what's going to happen
in a medical system can we
uh when we when we see that there's some
complicated process going on of some
cell some tumor some this some that
um you know to what extent can we
predict what it's going to do
well one of the lessons of my new kind
of science
is this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility so you might
think if you know the rules by which
something operates if you know what
every individual cell is going to do
and you know how each cell replicates or
whatever else
then you might say okay given that we
know the rules by which this works we
should be able to work out what the
large-scale consequences of those rules
will be
well one of the big results of the
science that i've done
is that that isn't the case that it's
that it's actually quite ubiquitous
if you just pick programs even kind of
at random
to find programs where even though you
know what the program is even though
you know know what the underlying rule
is to work out the overall behavior
is the only way you can really do it is
by following each step
in the actual uh execution of the
program you can't sort of jump ahead and
say so i know what it's going to do in
the end
i think that point is really important
for medicine
that is it's something where you can say
well we know
the rules by which this works but then
what's it actually going to do
well it may be very hard to tell for
example in the immune system
it is very likely the case that things
that we think
we you know the things that happen in
the immune system the reason it's hard
to have intuition about what the immune
system is going to do in a particular
case
is because of this phenomenon of
computational irreducibility
that even though you might know the
basic rules by which these immune
[Music]
cells interact that um
that it's hard to tell what the overall
consequences will be
so for example in the case of you know
could
a vaccine stimulate autoimmunity well
autoimmunity means so so
normally our immune system is set up our
sort of sophisticated that two different
versions of the immune system the
so-called primary immune system and the
adaptive immune system
the one that we mammals and things like
that have is a
immune system which learns in the first
few years of our life for
in the sort of pre uh pre-teen
period of our lives kind of learns what
molecular structures correspond to cells
that are part of
us and what correspond to nasty outside
invaders that we should attack with our
immune systems
so the adaptive immune system has this
process of learning
what kind of what kind of things should
be attacked and what kind of things are
self
if it makes a mistake and it says
actually that kind of cell
that is really part of you it's you know
a pancreatic beta cell or it's a
it's a myelin sheath of a nerve or
something like this that's actually part
of
your your organs
um in autoimmunity and autoimmune
diseases
what happens is that the immune system
makes a mistake
and starts attacking those cells um as
well as attacking external marauders so
to speak
and um and so for example in a in a um
uh in a vaccine what one's doing is
stimulating
the immune system to recognize
a type of attacker let's say the spike
protein of the covet 19 uh
virus um and um that one's
ones making it recognize that so it's
ready
and when it's exposed to some
potentially quite small number of of uh
you know you
you you inhale so a few virus particles
that the system is ready to attack and
so it can swing into action quickly and
put enough
immune effort behind getting rid of
those invaders
that the invaders never get to start
replicating in large numbers and cause
trouble
so that's kind of the idea of the
vaccine but but things can happen
like that it can be the case that just
as your immune system is learning to
attack the spike protein
that the uh that there are pieces of the
spike protein whose sequence looks too
close to something that is actually part
of you
or whose structure looks whose uh
geometrical structure looks too close to
something that's part of you a
geometrical structure
at a molecular scale looks too close to
something that's part of you
and so your immune system then suddenly
learns that it should be attacking
something
which turns out to be part of you and
that's that's bad because that produces
autoimmunity
but knowing how that works and being
able to sort of trace through
you know in the immune system so
you know just as we have antibodies that
uh can kind of recognize uh bad cells or
cells that have bad viruses inside them
and so on
and mark those cells um for for
later attack um the uh you know they're
about
the the antibodies work at a molecular
scale and they have
variable they have pieces of protein
immunoglobulins
that um can have
any where they sort of have randomly
picked sequences and they're about 10
billion different kinds of antibodies
that us humans can produce and we're
always producing randomly
lots of these different lots of these
different kinds of antibodies and then
the thing that happens is
when there's an attacker whose structure
whose molecular signature
matches one type of antibody out of
those 10 billion let's say
then there's a mechanism for that type
of antibody to get amplified and you get
more and more of those kinds of
antibodies
which is what leads to uh the
both the attack on the um but leads to
sort of
setting up the sort of the the attack on
the attacker so to speak
um or in the case of a vaccine getting
you ready to attack the attacker worthy
attacker to arrive for real so to speak
um
but one of the questions is always okay
so you're producing the antibodies
but the antibodies can uh themselves
represent things that can coat things
and and that you could um
uh you could end up with too many
antibodies so you end up with
anti-antibodies
and you end up with a whole hierarchy a
whole network of different
kinds of antibodies and anti-antibodies
and so on and so on and so on
which is all somehow maintained in some
kind of dynamic equilibrium
in us in ways that are not totally well
understood
and in fact there are two principal
kinds of cells in the
uh well many kinds of cells in the
immune system there are two white blood
cell types
uh b cells and t cells and uh the b
cells are the ones that um are
associated with antibodies and antibody
production and so on
antibodies themselves are much smaller
little pieces of protein
um but uh the t cells are the ones
that uh are also involved in immunity
so one one place where you sort of have
a memory of what's going on is in b
cells that can produce uh collections of
antibodies
that will attack some particular
attacker so to speak but
t cells are also responsible for
t cells are used in different places the
immune system
um they're used there's a the so-called
killer t cells which are
which are t cells that kind of go in and
finish uh the job
when something has been marked by by
antibodies and so on and so on and so on
but but uh something which i must say i
was only dimly aware of
before recent times is that t cells
themselves
can be sort of encode immunity
so just as there are all these different
possible kinds of antibodies produced by
b cells
there are also there's a t cell receptor
which is a region of the surface of the
t
cell which can determine what the t cell
can bind to what
what kinds of cells that t cell will
uh will attach itself to and potentially
attack
and so turns out for coronaviruses of
which covered 19 as an example
t-cell immunity is actually an important
thing
and um the uh but that wasn't you know
in sort of the standard story of
immunology that was
it was known but it was not an
emphasized thing it turns out to be
pretty important
and it turns out that's probably one of
the long-term
places where immunity whether by the
memory of immunity
gets stored for us for things like
coronaviruses and it's not clear for
example when you look at um
um uh you know vaccines and things
there's a question of to what extent the
um
uh that's generating antibody response
to what extent it's generating t
cell immunity and uh in the in the in
the trials of these vaccines
both things were measured and um uh
it's more difficult to measure the
antibody measuring
the um antibody productions is a
considerably easier
piece of laboratory practice than
measuring the t cell receptor which
actually requires
genome genetic sequencing and other
kinds of things
um i think at least i think it requires
that i don't think there's a way to do
it with just
pure assays um the uh
but anyway and it seems to take i know
as a practical matter it takes these
labs weeks to come back with
t-cell immunity results whereas uh the
uh
antibody uh measurements seem to come
back in a few days
um but in any case that uh let's see we
were talking about
so i mean the whole structure of the
immune system and this dynamic
equilibrium that's maintained by all
these different kinds of cells and so on
it's a pretty complicated thing it's a
very computational kind of thing
and getting intuition about what's going
on is a story i think of things like
computational irreducibility
and other kinds of phenomena in fact i
was just thinking that some of the
things we've done for our recent project
in
in understanding fundamental physics and
the way that there are sort of these
interactions between immune system cells
may actually be something that that we
can
make a model of using the same formalism
as we've used for physics i don't know
whether that will work yet
but um the immune system has been very
hard to understand and it's very hard to
get intuition about what's going to
happen
there are some sort of pieces of what
goes on where you can say
we understand that but there's an awful
lot of it that's pretty hard to
understand
um so um
the question here uh
i mean talking about medicine further
the um
i think so sort of the story of
computational irreducibility
how computationally should you think
about medical processes
so here's another thing i thought about
recently if you look at a medical
textbook
you will often see sort of flow charts
of this effect that affects that you
know
the level of this hormone goes up it
will produce this
it will cause that to go down it's it's
a very kind of a sort of a
a a definite chart of this causes that
and so on
well the actual sort of collection of
of chemical concentrations in our cells
it's a pretty complicated story and
whether you can really
tell that story in terms of this
produces that produces that produces
that
this sort of very sequentialized story
is not clear
and in fact i've been suspecting that
the way that
a lot of kind of the molecular scale
computation because in a sense
we biological systems are the only known
working example of kind of molecular
scale computation
in our in us in every cell in our bodies
all the time
there are all these essentially
computational processes happening
molecules are binding molecules have
have have complicated sequences they
generate other molecules they do other
things
you can think of that as a great big
computation and the question is
if we were going to write a programming
language for example to describe that
computation what would it look like
would it be something that has
you do this then you do this and you do
this then you do this or is it something
where there's lots of different threads
happening in parallel
i suspect it's more that lots of
different threads happening in parallel
and it's been super difficult for us to
make
ways to sort of make languages that
describe that kind of process
and so i kind of suspect that part of
the story of why
biology and medicine is difficult is
that
it's been hard to have a sort of
description language
for that um uh
for that kind of biological process um
that
you know the idea that it's this causes
that causes that very sequentialized
it's probably not correct
it's probably not the right sort of meta
way to think about
biological processes i mean the the big
meta discovery of biology in 1953
was the discovery of the dnas uh the
kind of
genetic information on dna the fact that
we can encode
the structure of all of our proteins and
the way that ultimately
we build a biological organism in terms
of for example for us humans the six
billion base pairs
that exist along the dna molecule um in
every in every one of our cells
and the fact that one could think about
sort of genetics as being a story of
this
digital information the six billion base
pairs of digital information
um was kind of a crucial organizing
principle
for understanding genetics and
understanding how heredity worked and so
on
in terms of how biology works on sort of
an ongoing basis what happens in all of
our cells
what happens in the immune system uh
what happens in other
sort of dynamical processes in us we we
don't have as good a
kind of a a large-scale framework for
thinking about that and i've kind of
come to this
recently come to this suspect that it
all has to do with
this kind of notion of uh um
well what we call in our physics project
multi-way systems
these things where there are multiple
sort of threads of history that you can
consider
multiple different chemical reactions
that can all be happening in parallel
and finding a way to sort of understand
all of those together
which i think is difficult for us humans
because we're really programmed
we're really set up in fact our very i
think the very essence of our
consciousness
has a lot to do with the
sequentialization of of events
and time so to speak so it's kind of
necessary to do something
different from that to understand these
kinds of biological processes
at least that's my my current suspicion
um and
you know will that lead us to something
where we have a better just like in
genetics
before dna was discovered to have this
digital information
people had a zillion different effects
that they were talking about and this
thing happened and that thing happened
it's all incredibly complicated and then
there's an organizing principle
we don't really have that for sort of
systematic biology right now
systems level biology and maybe that's
something that can come
as a result of thinking about things
like multi-way systems and multi-weight
computation
and so on we're not there yet i will
tell you as a sort of historical point
um
a person called sydney brenner who was
uh i think the main discoverer of
messenger rna
the thing that's used in the vaccine
that i just got yesterday for example
um the uh uh he discovered that and when
was it and probably
before 1960. don't remember exactly when
but anyway
uh sydney banner is is uh no longer
alive but
but um uh he was a a lively person and
he came to see me
every few years i guess and uh every
time he would say
you should be working on biology all the
stuff you're doing about all of these
kind of computational ideas
biology needs this this is how um this
is how you should pursue biology
and and he himself actually had had a
long time interest in computation when
he was a
medical student in south africa he'd
written a letter to alan turing for
example
um which uh uh and sort of been very
interested in
in kind of the the idea of turing
machines and later touring's
work and applications to biology in
which turing did not use turing machines
and a kind of a little bit of a
cognitive disconnect there but but um
that was in the 1950s um but anyway so
cindy brenner was i think
the idea of messenger rna um is partly
born out of kind of sydney brenner
thinking in computational terms in terms
of things like turing machines and
and thinking about how biological
processes might work at that level and
later on well later on he did many other
things but in particular he was
responsible for the
uh the one organism the c elegans
nematode little
worm type critter um the one creature
whose full uh biological growth process
is known it's it's about
what is it a little less than two
thousand cells in the organism
and it's completely known how that
organism uh gets
gets grows up and that was that was the
result of sydney brenner kind of leading
that effort
in any case so uh
you know his question being asked about
the relationship of sort of
computational
ideas and to to medicine i mean i would
say
one other thing that um uh
is a long time thing that i've been
curious about and never really made that
much progress on
is is the following thing if you look at
medical diagnosis
okay there's a medical diagnosis is very
difficult
it's probably getting more difficult as
more is known because
the more that's known the more you know
you come in
and you've got some symptom and
you know it might not be obvious whether
that symptom is neurological to do with
nerves
gastrointestinal to do with your
intestines and so on
or whether it's you know something i
don't know some endocrine thing to do
with
uh the endocrine system and hormones and
all this kind of thing
it might not be known what it is you
know it's just like my neck hurts or
something
and um you know which of these things is
it well
the problem is the more that's known in
medicine the more it tends to be the
case that you have to have a specialist
in each one of those areas
in order to know a reasonable slice of
the knowledge that's known in those
areas
and so pretty quickly you have to treat
out you know which specialist do you go
to
and once you once you're talking to that
specialist it's like
that person is most likely going to say
well i'm only thinking about in terms of
my particular subsystem
and it's either well you have something
wrong with that subsystem or you don't
and getting you know up in the tree to
go
examine another subsystem really hard
often
in the in the structure both the
organizational structure of medicine
and sort of the intellectual structure
of medicine so you know medical
diagnosis
is difficult and probably getting even
more difficult i mean i have to say that
that i will say that as a person who's
just sort of interested in things how
how things work i have for a very long
time had sort of a
little bit of a hobby of doing medical
diagnosis um
um and um i i i have some friends who
are
who are rather good medical diagnosis
people who've kind of
gradually taught me things about it um
and uh you know i think i'm i'm not
terrible at this point
i'm i'm better than i'm better than i
think most mediocre doctors
let's put it that way i'm not sure
that's a necessarily a high bar but but
um um it's been it's interesting because
in medical diagnosis the i mean i this
is a
perhaps a relevant topic but perhaps
perhaps of interest to people
i mean the thing that i've noticed is
it's partly a probability story and it's
partly a story
of whether you can think about
probabilities in a clear enough way
so one of the issues is a very typical
thing is
you have some symptoms there are five
possible things that
are you know common causes of those
symptoms
okay maybe there's even one leading
possible cause of those symptoms
okay you go and you do more precise
tests and then you say
nope that's not it the tests say that's
not the cause
then you go and you explore other things
you spend months exploring all these
other things
and pretty soon you've concluded it's
none of those five things
well it has to be something and the
mistake the probability mistake is this
that first thing that leading
possibility
that you kind of proved it wasn't
people almost never go back to that they
say up
we we excluded that we're done and
that's wrong because by the time you
excluded everything else
the probabilities of the tests that you
thought excluded that thing
themselves being wrong having some kind
of false negative false positive
rate whatever is sufficiently large that
yeah you really have to look at that one
again
because after you've exhausted
everything else you've got to go back to
that one and say
was it really the case if those tests
had had a three percent probability
of not catching the thing and you've
excluded everything else then go back
and look at that again
because maybe you hit that three percent
of the tests didn't work in that
particular case
and people are are remarkably bad
um at doing that reverting back to
things that to hypotheses they already
thought they excluded
i mean it's also one of my meta
principles perhaps unfair but but i
think
um is uh you know there's a lot of a
priori
sort of assumptions made for example in
the medical profession
where you know very typical thing is you
know a young doctor who's just been
through medical school
well in medical school you know you get
to see
all kinds of exotic things that can
happen and
um so the young doctors a priori
probabilities for different kinds of
things
uh are enhance the rare diseases
whereas an older doctor who's been in
practice for 40 years
it's like look i've never seen one of
those so it's like the april i probably
said yeah i saw it at the medical school
you know
years and years ago but i've never seen
one of those in reality so
there's a tendency to kind of over
assume that
everything people have is something
common so it's kind of like the
the young doctors over diagnosed rare
diseases and old doctors over diagnosed
common diseases
um at least that's a you know that it's
again it's one of these probability
things of
what's the a plural probability it's
like you know you come in
and you've got something and somebody
says you have this extremely rare
tropical disease
and it's like no i don't and i said but
look you've got all the symptoms of this
extremely rare tropical disease
and it's like well look i haven't been
to anywhere tropical
ever in my life and you know where on
earth would i have got this tropical
disease
and that's it's like well it is true
that your symptoms perhaps match this
tropical disease
but in fact the chance that you have it
is incredibly small
it's sort of a mistake of probability
assessment to say that
it's it's sort of it's like it's like if
you were um
uh it's like for a search engine you
know you have a page that
incredibly well matches the the things
you're searching for but it's a very
unpopular page on the web
where do you put it in the search
rankings and so on so
in any case there are these kinds of um
issues in medical diagnosis i mean i've
been interested actually
oh when was it 10 15 years ago i i put
quite a lot of work into
trying to understand how one would make
sort of automated medical diagnosis work
better
um partly because certain kinds for
example these probability mistakes
you can avoid making those probability
mistakes if you automate things
um you also can you know one of the
issues in medical diagnosis
is that that it tends to be the case
that a lot of diagnosis is made
from taking medical histories which have
rather sparse amounts of information
but today you know there are all these
sensors that you can have all these
elaborate tests you can do
um that are very broad spectrum things
for example you know you can sequence
your whole genome i did that
for myself what 11 years ago or
something now um
and uh you know that's a lot of data um
and it's like how do you use this data a
lot of traditional medical diagnosis is
like do you have a or b
okay if it's a then it might be this if
you have if it's b it might be that
it's not here's a gigabyte of data now
what can you conclude from that i mean i
you know my own
feeling is that the future of medical
diagnosis is much
more right now what happens is
you say there's something wrong you know
my
these you know this particular type of
cell in my
liver is doing this and that and et
cetera et cetera et cetera
and but the fact is there's a huge
diversity of things that can go wrong
and it's not the case and to bucket it
and say
okay you have disease x is
is often sort of missing the point it
isn't the case so here's an
interesting question that you can
you can ask if you look at biological
organisms right they fall into species
they speciate there's you know there's
cats there's dogs there's not a cat dog
combination um but if you look at
medical diseases should they do they
speciate
so to speak is it the case that medical
diseases can be separated into
you either have this or you have that
um probably much less so probably
when it comes to uh you know there's
there's probably a much more complicated
story let me mention something so so
back
when i was a kid and learning a little
bit about biology you know it was like
what is what's in blood okay it's red
blood cells it's white
blood cells okay that's you know you'd
learn it's white blood cells
okay great well of course today it's not
just white blood cells
it's you know cd8 positive t cells with
uh
et cetera et cetera et cetera it's it's
very much more finely granulated
and what you realize in the end is
there's just huge numbers of different
possible populations of cells maybe
almost an infinite number of possible
kinds of cells
and this idea that you can sort of
bucket them all and just say it's a
white blood cell
you know that's all there is to say
about it isn't really right
and so again when you think about
medical diagnosis
this question of whether you can bucket
things into a limited number of possible
diagnoses
which you can sort of describe in words
and assign diagnosis codes to
it's not clear that that's really the
right thing i mean for example in
nowadays in
oh the the standard diagnosis code
system used in the us
is a thing called icd-9 which has i
think about 30 000
possible diseases that are listed out
and it's kind of a hierarchical system
that lists out about 30 000 diseases
icd-10 is the kind of emerging thing
uh used in many places and it i think
has about a hundred thousand diseases
so the question is are there really a
hundred thousand sort of species of
disease
that we can assign to us humans or is it
more like an
arbitrary number an unknown number you
know an arbitrarily large number
that depend on uh you know the
particular configuration of
of uh surface proteins on such and such
a kind of cell
and there are an infinite number of
possibilities for that rather than just
saying oh you have
disease x so the question is in the
future
will it be the case that we still give
this kind of medical diagnosis
type of type of thing where we have a
name for what's going on
because in in general what you can
expect is that
you know you'll have a treatment for
what's happened and that treatment will
probably be much more detailedly
programmable
so for example the um
uh in um you know a typical drug
molecule
and there are only i don't know what two
thousand different kinds of drug
molecules
that are approved something like that um
a drug molecule
most drugs right now what they do is
they're a molecule it's a certain shape
and that molecule fits into the shape of
some other molecule in you
so for example the molecule for the drug
can
can kind of fit into some particular
other molecule in you and block that
other molecule from operating or it can
enhance the operation of that molecule
but it's a very static kind of thing the
molecule is just a certain shape
it moves around it attaches it does its
thing uh
one can imagine a world of sort of
algorithmic drugs
where the molecule itself or maybe some
complex of molecules
acts more like a molecular computer and
sort of makes decisions much like the
immune system
has sort of a mechanism for acting more
like a molecular computer
and making more complex decisions rather
than just saying does it bind or not
um it's so low it starts with it does it
bind or not
question but um so you know this kind of
idea so you potentially have these
algorithmic drugs certainly something
coming
you know people talk about a lot
personalized medicine you know given
your particular genome for example
can you make a specific drug that will
be appropriate for you now
now a lot of what that is right now is
is this drug
that is an existing drug going to work
better or worse on you et cetera et
cetera et cetera
i think one of the uh potential silver
linings
from this pandemic that we've been in is
that these vaccines that that got
so acceleratedly developed and and
approved
the uh the mr messenger rna vaccines the
mrna vaccines the
pfizer moderna vaccines um those
vaccines make use of kind of
a custom created uh kind of
sequence that's that's being fed to the
immune system normally
you develop a vaccine and you and you
sort of uh it's not something where you
could just type on a computer i want
this sequence
put that in the vaccine it's developed
in a much less
sort of in a much more chemical way much
less
informational kind of way but these
vaccines and and they were you know
originally when
when the you know a year ago uh the
companies that developed these it was a
matter of days for them to produce a
vaccine
that would potentially be a vaccine that
would
uh you know be effective against this
particular virus
um it took a lot longer to figure out
the precise dosing and
which particular one of the possible
sequences was the right one to use
et cetera et cetera et cetera um but but
um
and one of the things the reason that
that technology existed
is because people have developed it for
cancer
for being able to essentially have the
our immune systems
go attack cancer cells which usually
they're not able to do because the
cancer cells
tend to look too much like ourselves to
be able to be distinguished by the
immune system
but if you can make sort of a a
vaccine-like thing
that enhances the immune system and says
yeah this thing here is really bad
you should go attack that it has the
potential to
attack cancer cells um and to be a a
therapy for for cancer
um and so one of the things that is
probably going to be a result
of this pandemic story is the whole
lipid nanoparticle delivery mechanism
from mrna vaccines which was
what um got implemented is something
that can be used for
for arbitrary mrna vaccines and
potentially you know if one has a
particular tumor with a particular
genetic sequence because tumors are are
mostly a story
of uh cells that end up with different
genetics
than your cells um and uh
um and genetics that causes those cells
to replicate without bound
um by the way in terms of sort of the
computational way of thinking about
things
one of the kind of classic problems with
uh
with programs with turing machines um
the very idealized model of computation
developed by alan turing back in 1936
um the one of the classic problems is
the so-called halting problem
if you've got this program you start it
running will it run forever
go into a loop or something or will it
eventually halt
and in a sense that is the same problem
as tumors
because the definition of a of a
malignant tumor
is that it just keeps growing it doesn't
it doesn't know to stop
i mean us us humans our usual growth
processes
stop there are certainly lower organisms
where that isn't the case where the
organism will just keep growing all its
life it will keep adding more and more
cells but us humans are not like that we
grow until we're
sometime in our teens or something and
we stop um
and uh uh unless something like a tumor
develops
in which case um that just keeps growing
and that's eventually what causes
trouble
but um uh in any case the so it's it's
kind of a classic halting problem-like
thing
given this particular genetic sequence
will that lead to growth that goes on
forever doesn't halt
or will it stop that's again one of
these computational irreducibility
stories
of whether how you can even tell that
but any case
the um i was just going to say that i
think
that the way that sort of medical uh
treatment is going to end up working in
the end is these very much more
personalized
uh customized uh you know algorithmic
drugs particular sequences for
you know uh fed to the immune system in
a particular way those kinds of things
and so then the the currently the kind
of the
the workflow of medicine is you have
symptoms
you get a diagnosis based on the
diagnosis you get a treatment
you implement the treatment you see what
effect that has on symptoms
but the sort of a different workflow
is you go straight from symptoms to
essentially a computed
treatment there's no diagnosis in the
middle there's nothing that says
this is the name for the thing you have
there's no discrete diagnosis
code it's just given these symptoms
given these measurements that got made
this is the algorithmic drug that should
be produced this is the
immune system sequence that should be
used and then
you directly apply that and so it
becomes much more
like a a little bit more like sort of a
in
the financial markets for example like a
quantitative finance sort of automated
system
that's just watching what the um uh you
know what the prices do and figuring out
what to do rather than something where
you say oh
i know what that is that's a a head and
shoulders growth
curve that exists in this financial
system or something
and therefore i will do this it's rather
going straight from the data
to the what to do and i suspect that's
the way medicine will go
um in the end and that is much more
going to be a thing where you're kind of
watching it as you might watch a
financial portfolio and saying let me
add a little bit more of this a little
bit less of that
and and so on rather than the kind of oh
are you sick or are you not sick do you
do this or do you not do this type thing
and i think um well there's there's lots
more to say about this it's it's a
interesting topic of of um uh you know
just as
for humans we have maybe a hundred
thousand different diseases that we know
i've been curious for software systems
like for a computer's operating system
you know can you break down the things
that go wrong to the computer's
operating system
into categories of disease so to speak
you know you plug the wrong thing into
the into the computer
there was trauma associated with some
device driver that uh
saw a bizarre pattern of of um of data
coming in or there was um uh something
where the memory
where some memory corruption happened it
was some sort of disease of the memory
subsystem or whatever
you know what is the classification of
such diseases
a while ago when will from alpha was
much was much newer
we had trouble with the servers for
orphan alpha um
crashing and so for a while we were
interested in the mortality curves for
servers
that is all kinds of problems would
build up they would get all kinds of
issues and then
eventually after a few hours the server
would crash
and so we started looking at the
mortality curves and comparing them
to mortality curves for biological
organisms and they were actually
surprisingly similar
um then we actually managed to tweak
some things and fix some things and
it turns out we solved the lifetime
problem so we stopped researching that
particular thing so we don't know
we never got a general theory of kind of
mortality for operating systems
but it's an interesting thing to to
potentially explore
um gosh that was a long answer i'm sorry
to to
um uh
let's see oh boy there's so many
interesting questions here
all right there's one from aaron here
what's the minimum amount of dna
that is obviously basic and could
perform universal computation will be
this some kind of lower bound
for the complexity of life people have
been interested in synthetic biology
in making sort of minimal from scratch
organisms
um we don't know the answer to what the
minimum sort of self-reproducing with
proteins organism
is there's some pretty small pretty
small ones i mean viruses don't
replicate themselves they have a host
um but uh the the answer is it's not
known
and i think people who try to get to
that
by making an engineering type design oh
we need to have the thing
have this piece so that it can do this
and this and this that will not give the
minimal result
the minimal result will probably be some
kind of sort of origin of life
experiment
where you just make all possible
sequences and you see which ones
reproduce themselves
i i know there have been some
experiments done along those lines but i
don't
think there's a definite result to that
at this time i mean i would guess that
the answer is going to be quite small i
mean
thousands of base pairs at most perhaps
even smaller than that
um but in a sense what you know part of
the
story i suppose is that well okay so one
of the issues is how much do we
you allow yourself outside of the dna
that is to what extent do you allow it
to be inside a cellular structure
because whenever you know there's a
there's more to the story
of of sort of what's passed down between
the generations in biological organisms
than just the dna
it's not only the dna but also the whole
cellular structure you know there is an
egg cell
and the that structure of that cell is
what
starts is what gets used to start
reproducing the next next organism and
so on
so it's a little bit unclear what what
you allow you know whether you allow the
sort of lipid bilayer
you know cell membrane and things like
that whether you allow other pieces um
in that story or whether it's um and if
you allow that
then my guess is it's it's i don't know
i would guess less than a thousand base
pairs but i don't know and that's not
known yet
um but uh uh but yes it's an interesting
question
given the apparatus given the
environment like
the cellular environment what's the
minimum size program
in that cellular environment that's a
sort of quite different question i mean
it's in a sense it's like saying you
know what's the minimum sized universal
computer
that you can make as a turing machine as
a cellular automaton
as a register machine well all of those
have some
ambient apparatus for doing
their computation um and then you're
simply asking within that ambient
uh within that ambient apparatus how big
is the actual
sort of rules for the actual thing
itself and so i suppose the same
question would exist for biology and my
own guess would be
less than a thousand base pairs but i
don't know um
okay a few more general questions and
then um
uh well actually here's a question from
rj is that fundamental computational
boundary to super intelligent ai doctors
being able to capable of connecting all
medical specialties
unfortunately i think the answer is yes
i think it's a story of computational
irreducibility again
it's like you are an organism that is
performing a computation the computation
is doing something bad
can you tweak the computation so that
can you make an intervention
that says change these bits so to speak
to make the computation go back on the
on the right track again
the difficulty is computational
irreducibility says you may not know
what the consequences of changing those
bits are
you may not know you know this
particular vaccine that seems to be good
for
getting you know um immunizing us
against this virus
maybe it has the consequence that in 30
years it makes us all grow
giant unicorn horns or something it's uh
it's but but it won't be clear for a
long time what the what the consequences
are
and i think on a more local scale in
medical interventions
it's in a sense computational
irreducibility is a story of never being
able to know what the consequences will
be
with with complete certainty so that
makes it sort of that's a limitation
on uh you know can one
come on set things up to kind of know
what's going to happen could one get the
right answer for what medical
intervention to make
and in general you know as you think
about sort of longevity and so on and
and uh you know how do we how do we live
longer and how do we fix
all the things that go wrong it's just
like how do you keep that
that computer operating system running
forever if we could go in and start
adjusting the bits and and controlling
this and that the other can we make our
computer just run forever
uh i was noticing that we have some
servers at our company that have been
running for 10 years
for example without being rebooted um so
you know that's an example of where the
operating system is
you know that's pretty good for for a
computer operating system
um the uh i think that um you know can
we
do the same thing for biological
organisms uh
even if with those operating systems
they probably didn't have intervention
but even if we allow ourselves to
intervene and say
we're going to make this change this
change this change this tweet this tweak
that week
can we do that in a way that sort of
keeps us running forever so to speak
and it may get arbitrarily difficult to
do that it may be that
that you know a tweet another tweak
another tweak another tweak
that sort of becomes arbitrarily
difficult to do it i think somebody
asked here
um about uh
let's see somebody was asking something
about longevity research
um yeah
nutty was asking why are we not
prioritizing research in longevity
so you know the real question is why do
we get old
what actually happens and what can we do
about it
you know we don't even really know what
aging is
there are several different mechanisms
there's sort of oxidative
damage to cells of molecules generally
just starting to sort of degrade there's
uh
there's sort of genetic degradation
there's the telomeres which are the end
caps on our dna
50 let's start off we start with about
50 of them and it's like
they seem to degrade over the course of
a lifetime and over the course of
cell divisions although you seem to be
able to get more of them
and certainly for the next generation
there are enzymes that
that will um add in more telomeres so
it's not it's not really a one-way
street there
but there are these different mechanisms
that people know for sort of the general
things that seem to be degrade as one
gets older
um you know not a lot is known i mean
not there's no final this is it
it's not clear there will be a single
this is it it's known that there are
some organisms
that live longer shorter there's
correlations between different kinds of
things like metabolic rate and lifetime
things like that um there's cases of
organisms that can hibernate for a long
time all kinds of things
and you know back i remember
30 something years ago whenever i would
ask people about aging and longevity
and so on biologists they'd be like oh
no nobody studies that no you know
it's too difficult there's nothing to
say about it it's kind of a disreputable
field
i think perhaps as the population um
has sort of on average in countries like
the u.s got a bit older
um people have gotten more interested in
this and that there is a decent amount
of work that's going on
in aging and longevity and so on but but
certainly not
as much as there could be um and people
still think it's kind of like an
insolvable problem i mean it's kind of
like
you know back from uh you know from
every kind of um
you know story from thousands of years
ago it's like somebody wants to
achieve all mortality and find the
elixir of eternal life and so on or
eternal youth or whatever
um and uh you know people say that's
kind of that's just science fiction so
to speak
um and it isn't possible but it's not
clear it isn't possible
um and uh you know i think that's that
is certainly
the important challenge for for medicine
and biomedical research
is well can you make it possible because
that would be kind of neat
um and you can you can discuss the whole
question of whether
longer lives are good for society or
just good for the individual that's a
complicated question
i mean it's kind of one of the things
where where sometimes
um uh you know in a rather macabre way
it's sometimes said that the
the progress of science is measured in a
pre
procession of funerals so to speak in
the sense that once somebody has a
particular way of doing things
like doing science that they learn when
they're 20 years old or whatever
they'll just keep doing it their whole
lives and if their lives get longer and
longer and longer
they're going to be more and more people
who say this is the way to do it nothing
new is needed
and that can slow down progress if one's
interested in progress
um to have sort of this you know people
people being around a long time so to
speak i i think i think as
as somebody as an as an older person who
uh
enjoys their life i i think being around
longer seems like a pretty good idea
at least for the individual um and uh
you know that's a
that's a a story for that
um let's see questions here okay let's
take a couple more biology questions
here
um from aaron what makes hela cells
immortal how common are they in humans
uh was
okay so let me tell you the story of
that so um
uh back in the 1950s okay first point is
the typical cell that we have
cells divide they undergo mitotic
division
a cell breaks in blood divides in two it
ends up with two cell nuclei
the dna gets replicated etc um and
that's mitotic that's standard cellular
division and that happens
when we all start from a single cell and
the first stages of
of our existence consist of just
essentially exponential growth of cells
every cell just divides in two divides
in two divided two
etc um eventually that exponential
growth stops
being exponential and we end up as i was
mentioning earlier
we end up as humans with a with a fixed
number of cells
you know some number of what is it ten
trillion cells or something
um that is the um that is what we're
going to get
um you know with some slight changes and
you know you can um
uh uh but but that's basically the size
we're going to
get to we're not like i think is it
redwood
trees i think keep growing forever is
that right certainly some some types of
mollusks keep growing forever some fish
keep growing forever you know if you
have a goldfish it will just keep
growing and growing growing growing
growing
you know as as long as it lives um we
don't we don't work that way
um we we get to a fixed size and then
stop
well at the cellular level these mitotic
divisions
was discovered in the 1950s 1960s maybe
um a thing that's usually called the
hayflick limit
which is a cell it divides
then its progeny divide again they
divide again they divide again
that only happens about 50 times so a
given cell
starting from this sort of the the the
original first cell
you only get 50 divisions so
mathematically that means the maximum
number of cells you can get is 2 to the
50th from that
um that's just because each time you
divide but with two and
and that's the number of cells you can
get to so
one thing that was discovered in much
more recent times was
the sort of biological origin of that
limiting uh of that limitation
and what it seems to be is these things
called telomeres
um on our dna long strand of dna
all gets curled up but the ends of the
dna are things called telomeres which
are
repeats i think they're att i don't
remember what they are but there's some
some collection of a's and t's mostly
base pair sequences
which are just simple repeats and sort
of
when we're born well at least when we
start off
in as an embryo we end up with our cells
have 50
about 50 telomeres um
at the ends of every every uh piece of
dna
and those telomeres kind of hold the dna
together in some way
every time there's a replication one of
those telomeres sort of falls off at
least that's the first approximation
i say a first approximation because you
can go and of course i as a data
oriented person have done this for
myself
you can go and get your telomere lengths
measured um
it the standard genetic sequencing
doesn't do very well on these repeat
type things so it's kind of a special
measurement method to measure the
telomeres and uh you know it's it's uh
you get back this report that says you
are effectively such and such
old according to your telomere length
and uh
you know i felt proud because i counted
as being less old than i actually
am according to telomere length but
actually the footnote is
you know live lead a healthy life and
you'll get more telomeres
um so it's not clear as i say it's not
clear that's a fundamental limit but
that is a
there is this idea that cells only
replicate a certain number of times and
then stop
okay it's also the case that when you
actually grow cells in a you know in a
petri dish or something
the cells will grow and when they
physically run into other cells
there are chemicals released that cause
those cells normally to stop growing
and that's good if you're a mammal you
know you you you're going to get a fixed
size et cetera et cetera et cetera okay
what happens in tumors
is that mechanism is turned off both of
these mechanisms are turned off
the tumor cells just keep replicating
forever and
and that's a really bad thing if you're
you know given that we have like tendril
in cells or whatever
and you suddenly have a tumor which has
another trillion cells two trillion
cells etcetera etcetera etcetera
that's eventually going to kind of
strangle some some critical system
in you and that's that's a bad thing but
but that means that tumor cells can live
forever
and because they just keep replicating
they keep replicating they keep
replicating forever
and um a person named henrietta lacks
in the 1950s 1953ish maybe
uh died of some uh some particular kind
of tumor
and um the uh the the hospital she was
at
i had tissue samples and in a story i
don't know the full details of it but
it's a
it's a it's not a great story of medical
consent and
and the way that all of these things
work um but it was very early time then
and it wasn't the the definitions were
much less clear than they are today
but any case the the result was some of
the tissue from this person's tumor
um was was uh was growing
and it keeps on growing and it's grown
forever and so
you know the total number of you know
henrietta lacks cells and and dna
is huge and um because it's a very
standard
in in in biology labs when you're
testing
the effect on a human cell of such and
such a thing well you'll often use a
hela cell
um henrietta lacks cells so to speak um
so it's you know the particular details
of
of um uh you know of those cells i think
um uh i think henrietta lacks was an
african-american woman
um and so whatever the detailed genetics
of that
are those are the things that you know
the initial tests get made on
for almost every biological experiment
on human cells just because they're the
most common
kinds of um uh um
of of um uh of of cells used to test
things
when you get to fancier tests you test
on mice and things like that and then
there are these
sort of uh genetically pure lines of
mice that get bred for particular
purposes and so on
but when it's at a cellular level hela
cells are the most common and
and hela cells that works because and of
course the reason they're not
typical human cells is because they're
immortal cells
they they can just keep replicating
forever and
whether that matters for testing the
response of some
particular kind of drug or whatever else
it's not clear
you don't know that that's why you have
to go on and do other medical tests
but that's kind of the first step in is
it roughly going to work in a human cell
well if it works
if it doesn't work in these immortal
cells it probably will work in ordinary
human cells
um there's a question here why can't we
reproduce cell membranes
are they made of proteins yeah so cell
membranes do reproduce that they
they they simply form when a cell breaks
into
it forms two separate membranes but
that's a process that doesn't
uh let me see am i am i right here
that's a process that is more yeah
it's a it's a a more sort of chemical
process
it's not a genetically mediated process
there there are many things on the cell
membrane there are many little
little things receptor sites and things
like that that stick up through the cell
membrane
those are produced by the standard
genetic apparatus but the cell membrane
itself is a simpler object
that is really um you know purely
a sort of a pure uh molecular uh
thing that doesn't rely on the whole
apparatus of genomics and so on
um i i'm some friends of mine actually
had a i don't know what's happened to
what they were doing but they had a
company
for making artificial cells and i
suppose that the
the story of lipid nanoparticles is
probably not completely unlike
sort of having a very minimal artificial
cell so to speak
um and that's uh that's sort of a place
where the
the the rna can live um and uh
just like in an ordinary cell there's
you know there's this some
uh this membrane and inside is the
cytoplasm
and that that's the kind of the
gelatinous stuff
that all of the chemical reactions and
all the all the organelles
all the sort of pieces of the cell
operate
um okay
well let's see um
oh gosh lots of interesting questions
here my gosh
um okay that was enough for biology i've
spent nearly an hour talking about
biology but it was
it was fun so thanks thanks for asking
those questions
um let me see
what should we do here as a question
from a toure that's the more kind of
personal practices question it's like
how do you organize or prepare
for giving a talk i'm a terrible person
to ask that question of
because uh in fact
this happened just a couple of days ago
i was talking about the first
anniversary of our physics project
and i was complaining to my team that
because of various things i had
no time to prepare and
one person on my team observed that
i give much better talks when i haven't
prepared them and i have
so really for me
the um the beginning is very important
the um if i can get well a couple of
things
understanding a little bit about the
audience and getting some feel for the
audience is important
and at least having some image of what
the audience might be like
is important for me at least the very
beginning is important
if i'm off to a sort of a weird start
and i'm you know getting very very
technical and i'll go on very technical
or if i'm if i'm very kind of uh
i don't know you know the the start is
important and i have to
but then for me if it's a subject that i
know reasonably well
i'm you know probably preparation is not
the most important thing for me um now
you know i've given thousands and
thousands of talks in my life so it's
uh when i started off doing this i used
to prepare
these overhead projector transparencies
right i mentioned so that was a
these days it would be you know slides
and notebooks or powerpoint or whatever
it is
um that would be sort of an outline of
the talk
the thing you have to avoid though is
you know
reading off you know by the time you're
reading from the thing that is on the
screen
sort of all bets you know you've lost
everything because like
you put this thing up on the screen and
like the audience can see it
and like if you then read the words that
are on the screen it's like
why are we listening to this person
saying this we can just read it
um so i think uh and i tend to
uh you know when i do talks that involve
visual kinds of things i tend to have
what i usually call a slide farm which
is um
something where off screen on another
screen i'll have a whole collection of
possible images as thumbnails
that i can then pull up as a slide on
the main screen and that's a that's a
convenient way to do things
um and i have to say that that um uh
well it is the case for me i think i
give
my better talks are either completely
unprepared
or a hundred percent prepared i mean
there are cases where
i'm giving some very short remark on
something or some such other thing
where i know i have a lot to say for me
it's often
as you perhaps can tell from these uh uh
these live streams it's sometimes harder
for me to say things
shortly than longley so to speak and so
if i have to say i've got
two minutes to give some comment at some
you know ceremonial event of some kind
i'll often end up writing out every word
i'm going to say
because i know that i can't get you know
if i'm just starting and starting to
talk about things and so on
it'll be ten minutes that goes by before
i really said nothing so
so that's sort of my second my first
mode is don't prepare at all
and my second mode is um uh
have you know every word written out um
i think that
for me it helps that you know explaining
things
that one has explained things before
helps in explaining things again and i
will say that for example
uh these live streams are
very interesting for me they're very
educational for me like for example
today
i was talking about medical kinds of
things and some of the things that i
explained to you i'd never explained
that way before
and i came up with a better explanation
here than i'd ever had before
and hopefully i'll remember that
explanation the next time
and uh that that something like that
comes up and you know it's
sort of an incremental process of you
explain things and then you get better
at explaining those things
and most of the things i talk about i've
sort of
you know i'll have i'll have thought
about it before occasionally like i gave
a talk
um oh when was it a couple of weeks ago
about
my recent work on thinking about the
foundations of consciousness in its
relationship to physics
i'd never given a talk about that before
but i just written
a a piece about it so i had kind of a
the logical structure was in mind so to
speak about how it worked
um some of these things sometimes there
are
things which are comparatively simple
and logical structure sometimes they're
really
quite complicated in logical structure
and sort of holding in one's mind all
those steps
is is something which it's helped if
one's already written something about it
or
already given some parts of that
description before
but um i i don't think that all of those
aspects
apply to everyone and i think outlining
what you're roughly going to say yeah
i mean i guess i've done that i don't do
those much these days but but sort of
giving an outline of what i'm going to
say
um is you know that the five ten bullet
points or something of
of topics is is something that i have
found useful in the past
um
let's see
uh
boy all right
um
there's several very interesting
questions here and i'm i'm i'm trying to
avoid one that's going to get me into
into a giantly long discussion because i
don't have
too much more time today um there's a
question from zach here
how many hours should a scientist work
per day
uh i don't know i mean
i think it varies with person you know i
tend to
work pretty much if i'm not asleep
i'm not eating or generally
uh you know i i'll work i don't know i
haven't measured it precisely but i'm
guessing
around 14 15 hours per day um
and uh and you know for me
work is a is a thing with very fuzzy
boundaries
like for example the thing i've been
doing for the past hour
is it work is it not work i don't know
it's fun for me it's contributes to
things that i try and try to do as
productive things in the world
um you know it's it's so if you include
things like this i'm probably working
pretty much all the time i'm awake
um in that sense of work uh
i think that um if it comes if it's a
question of
you've got a blank sheet of paper you're
staring at it you're trying to figure
out the next thing to do
i don't spend a lot of time doing that
at all for me
it's very important to have these kind
of matrices in which i'm
structures in which i'm doing my work
like for example
if i'm writing a document about
something if i'm trying to
that is a way of kind of concretely
moving forward with something i'm
thinking about
if i'm trying to write a program about
something if i'm trying to
just do a live experiment do some kind
of
computational experiment these are
things which sort of allow you to
incrementally move forward
without being in the situation i'm
staring at a blank sheet of paper what
do i do next
i i spend a very small amount of time
in the equivalence of staring at a blank
piece of paper and figuring out what's
going to happen next
almost all the time that i spend doing
sort of sciencey things
i spend i'm writing a program i'm seeing
what happens when i run the program
i'm uh you know i'm writing a
description of what's going on i'm
trying to write an exposition of
something
i'm explaining it to people those kinds
of things that
they're things with structure i think it
is for me it would be very difficult to
just sort of sit and think in the
abstract
and for me it's been very important in
my life i've sort of alternated between
doing basic science and doing technology
kinds of things
and that alternation has been very
important it really helps
you know for example i'm i'm i'm working
on um
uh the um um
i'm working on uh some of these
questions about
oh parallel computation and these
multi-way things and all this kind of
stuff
and there's sort of theoretical
questions about that but
it's really useful to know what the
point is and one of the points is
i actually want to build this stuff into
wolfram language as a practical way to
do distributed computing
and having that sort of practical point
is a very important driver
of the more conceptual theoretical
things that i'm thinking about
so for me it's kind of like if you ask
how much time should one spend in sort
of unstructured scientific thought
the answer for me is very little how
much time in sort of
moving forward the the machinery the
mechanisms the actual
the actual think concrete things one's
doing a lot
um you know i i've noticed that i'm very
bad for example as
me as an example i'm i'm really bad
at just like thinking in the abstract
without a computer without even a piece
of paper
you know it's like if i'm just sitting
there
you know with just you know just
thinking about things in my mind
i don't think i do very well and i don't
think i can keep doing that for very
long very productively i feel like oh my
gosh i gotta write that down i've gotta
sort of
otherwise i'm kind of looping trying to
hold that in my memory
um so i don't forget that and then i
have to go on to the next thing but if
i'm concretely
you know doing something in a notebook
writing code this kind of thing
that gives me a structure that allows me
to kind of much more
effectively build up a bigger thought so
to speak i think one of the things that
um
i think there was a question actually
earlier about about languages and how
they affect the way we think about
things
for me sort of a lot of the things that
i do in science
base are based on sort of this
computational paradigm for thinking
about things
and having this computational language
language that i spent the last time many
decades
working on um you know that for me
is a is a critical environment a
language
in which to structure my thoughts about
computational kinds of things
and without that i just wouldn't be able
to build any significant tower
myself at least i don't know for other
people so much
that you know being able to build sort
of this complicated conceptual tower
it's like
as this computational idea and it's
concretely represented by this piece of
code which i can understand
it builds on this it builds on that it
builds into this it builds a tower
and that's where i can actually think
about things if it was like i gotta hold
it all in my head
it's um uh you know i don't know how it
works i
i know um in uh the movie coming out
it was uh the director of which i
happened
to know called uh which is a movie
version of dune
um and in the dune universe i know that
ais have been have been outlawed and so
the best they can do is have humans who
are all kind of juiced up and who
kind of are are kind of thinking like
computers i'm going to be interested to
see how
how they managed to treat the um the
kind of uh
the way that those humans do their sort
of human level computation i mean it's
it's kind of like
like having a program run in a human so
to speak
um and uh i don't think it works very
well i think that um
uh even you know in the dune universe
where they can have special guns of
humans and
that's that's what you get to do in
science fiction but in in in real life
so to speak with just
us us simple humans it doesn't work so
well now maybe maybe one day when
they're uh
you know as the symbiosis of us and
computers
gets better the sort of working together
of us and computers gets better
um it's unclear how that will work i
mean maybe as i think about something
you know for me writing a you know
wolfram language notebook or something
is concretifying the thoughts that i'm
having it's
taking the thoughts that i'm having
turning them into computational language
putting them on putting them down
letting them build up and so on
um and that for me is sort of a
symbiosis between me and the computer
now maybe there'll come a time when
you know we'll have enough linkage to
brains and things that our pure thoughts
will be able to be remembered external
to us
i don't know how well that will work
because i think that the crisping of our
thoughts
to turn them into a well-designed
language
may be something that is necessary it's
kind of like yes you could store that
it will be like storing every piece of
scratch work but it's not all that
useful
storing the scratch work is less useful
than storing your summary of the scratch
work so to speak
and so you know in a sense what we are
uh you know as we
turn things into language we are turning
our thoughts into something that's worth
storing so to speak
and by the time we've turned them into
language we might as well be saying them
writing them down whatever else
now the freedom that we have the thing
we haven't had is anything beyond human
natural language that's the important
role of computational language
is it's a way to to represent to
leverage
sort of what computation makes possible
over and above
what is merely what we humans can think
about and think in terms of ordinary
human natural language
um uh
okay well okay it's very tempting to go
on and and um
and uh talk about more of these
questions but i think
it is um it is well i could go on for a
little tiny bit here
all right drink of water and then i go
on for a tiny bit
and um all right a couple more here
okay there's a there's a question from
travel
why isn't nuclear power used more and is
there a way to make it smaller and safer
so it can be used like a portable power
generator
okay there's a there's a physics problem
which is
how does nuclear power work well it
works using nuclear chain reactions
a nucleus of some radioactive element
like uranium-235 um
spontaneously self-destructs very slowly
lifetime for a single uranium-235
atom is in the billion-year type range
um when it self-destructs it produces
essentially these
particles these fragments of the nucleus
they go out
and they hit other nuclei which cause
those nuclei
to not spontaneously self-destruct but
to be
to be so causes them to immediately
self-destruct they're kind of kicked
and they self-destruct and that process
produces this kind of chain reaction
where more and more and more nuclear
self-destructing
and it's the self-destruction of those
nuclei that um
uh the destruction of those nuclei i
should say that causes energy to be
released and that's where nuclear energy
comes from
is the the sort of the the
disintegration of those nuclei
and nuclear fusion which is what's using
hydrogen bombs and things it's it's the
other way but for these
for ordinary nuclear power as nuclear
power operates right now
without fusion devices um it's all about
the self-destruction of very large
or the destruction of very large nuclei
um
into into smaller pieces and that's
something that
relies on this kind of chain reaction
idea well
there is a certain um
not sure if this is fully correct but i
think it's correct i mean the
there's a certain uh critical mass
that is associated with the the minimum
size
that you need in order to have a
self-sustaining chain reaction how does
that work that's that
relies on
neutron mean free paths how does that
work
um okay a bit more thought required
there but my
there's a there's a definite critical
mass that is necessary
to have a um a self-sustaining nuclear
reaction and i and that that critical
mass is a certain size and that's
so there's a lower limit on the size you
need for that
to to work um and um
i think that the um uh
so so that's one physical limitation um
i think it's
it's like you know i don't know it's
it's a sphere
how big is it like i think 20
centimeters maybe for uranium-235
uh diameter of the sphere something like
that if i remember correctly
um and i think there's no way to make a
self-sustaining nuclear reaction with it
with less material than that i think
um so that's one limitation
the other limitation is uh
you know how do you make it safe well
there are there are ideas of having you
know
a typical nuclear reactor power station
for example
it's in this big pressure vessel and
these pressure vessels are supposed to
last maybe a hundred years
and you know that they're they're sort
of rated i think they're originally
rated for 30 years but mostly they
they've been extended to like hundred
year lifespans and things
and um you know there's kind of an idea
that there might be ways to make nuclear
power
so that you can just put it in something
that will be permanently encased
that's something people are interested
in doing when you have uh
nuclear spent nuclear fuel that still is
radioactive
how do you embed it in something like
glass or some such other thing
so that it will just stay uh you know
never escape you can just
bury it somewhere and forget about it
and a million years from now it will
still be there and nothing will have
destroyed it
that's a challenging thing to be sure
about because it depends on geology
and all kinds of things and it's an even
more challenging thing what are the
warning signs that you put up
that are supposed to work even 10 000
years from now
that's an interesting problem if you
know if there was a sign on a pyramid
that said you know uh doom to everybody
who enters here
um well if we didn't know those
hieroglyphs now
it's it's unclear that we would know
that this is a you know don't enter here
bad news bad idea
the pyramid will collapse or whatever
else you know that signage
would probably have been lost in the
last four thousand years or at least
it's
the understanding of how to read it um
but i mean in terms of
of um i think the main problem with with
uh nuclear power as a sort of safety
issue
is the the very fundamental components
are these radioactive elements and
radioactivity is bad
and when radioactivity gets out as it
did in like the fukushima
uh nuclear accident in in um uh
in japan um it's uh you know nuclear
uh it's kind of like you know it's like
like okay this virus that's infected the
world right
how much actual virus is there if i
think the total amount of virus
would fit in one's hand that all the
little virus particles that have
gone all over the earth and infected all
sorts of people
you know the total number of these
particles is really small so it's just
because
when you distribute that broadly enough
and each individual virus
is causes enough trouble that it really
matters
and it's a little bit the same with
nuclear kinds of things that
you know a pretty small volume of
nuclear material
if spread out over a large area um you
know each
each particular uh piece of you know
each particular grain of dust that is
radioactive and things
can cause trouble and the fact that that
can be very widely distributed
that's that's sort of a bad thing now
obviously when it gets dilute enough
like with the virus
you know if you're outside and you're
not you know
breathing right at somebody else you're
not going to get you know you're not
going to get infected with the virus
because
the earth's atmosphere is pretty huge
and by the time that little virus
particle is out floating around in the
earth's atmosphere
the you know the chance that it gets to
you and one virus particle on its own is
almost certainly not enough to lead to
infection
um it's it's um uh it's it's sort of an
absurdly
uh you know the orders of magnitude is
such that it's absurdly impossible
to get infected that way but um
but you know with with radioactivity the
difficulty is that just
it can get spread very easily it's just
individual grains of dust or something
or individual even at the level of
individual atoms and so that's
you know it's you have to really enclose
it very well and that's problematic
now it's not impossible to do that i
mean there are plenty of things which
if they get out cause a lot of trouble
they're plenty of uh
very nasty toxic chemicals that are kept
nicely enclosed in things so it's it's
not an impossible thing by any means
it doesn't help sometimes that
radioactivity because it's releasing
energy
makes things hot and so that that can
make it harder to
to enclose things but i don't think
that's a i don't think that's a
fundamental limitation and people
people design these different kinds of
methods for developing
uh nuclear power systems one of the
issues right now
is your average nuclear power station is
really expensive i mean
you know a billion dollars is not out of
you know it's not an unreasonable price
for a nuclear power station one of the
reasons for that is that essentially
every nuclear power station is a custom
built
thing it's like we've got the site it's
sitting in this place it's going to have
these characteristics it's
there's no production line where
somebody's mass producing of their power
stations
um if somebody built that production
line probably you'd get the price down
to i don't know 500 million dollars
per nuclear power station and that would
be a much different proposition
from what it is today um but the cost of
of producing you know the making the
production line that's really expensive
um and so the unit cost once you've got
the production line
up and running is significantly lower
but you have to make a commitment
to just be generating you know thousands
of nuclear reactors
that would be put in different places so
it's
uh you know it's it's an economic issue
that's kind of difficult to to unravel
all right i'm there's several questions
here that i really want to
talk about the next next time here but
but um
there's one about uh uh computational
irreducibility
and economies and things i might
actually have more to say about that
next week because i've actually been
thinking about that recently and uh just
okay my last question for today from fat
man here
um what do you feel is the place of
philosophy in modern science
okay interesting question so
you know in some sense philosophy
is about thinking about things before
you have a very well-defined framework
for thinking about them
so you know philosophy is like think
about it in the most flexible way you
can
or at least that's you know that's a
definition of philosophy
as soon as you've got science you've got
you know for example you've got
mathematics you've got these particular
areas
it's like well now we've got a framework
we don't need the general way of
thinking about things
we can go and use the specific way of
thinking about things
that is much more efficient than the
general philosophical way of thinking
about things
i mean it's worth remembering that a
history of science for
for many many years in the you know in
the history of science
it was you know science was natural
philosophy
you know from aristotle uh in in a
couple of thousand years ago
to uh to well into
until the 1600s um it was really a story
of if you want to know about nature what
you would do
is you would think about natural
philosophy you would
ponder how nature works by thinking
about it using general thinking so to
speak
and so you would what people imagined
was that just by thinking about stuff
you'd figure out how the natural world
works
now when science got developed when
modern science got developed when
mathematical science got developed
there became these frameworks which
could zoom forward
and figure things out in a much more
efficient way than by just
thinking in a general thinking kind of
way you know i saw this in a very
explicit way
well i should say a couple of things so
first of all famously in 1687
important data in history of science was
when isaac newton published his
principia mathematica
the full title of which in latin was
mathematical principles that's what
principia mathematica means
of natural philosophy so what newton was
doing was going from this
this just think about nature by using
the general tools of thinking and
philosophy
to mathematical principles apply
mathematical thinking
to think about natural philosophy it was
sort of the watershed
of go from pure sort of thinking like
with philosophy to using mathematics to
think about the natural world
and at this point we now have this other
paradigm of computation to think about
the natural world
but uh the the um uh so i
i i got to see very sort of directly
in 2009 when we released more from alpha
uh one of the things well from alpha is
all about
is answering questions about the world
and
there have been efforts to make such
systems to do that
for for many years before before from
alpha came out
and one of the things was that all those
systems
kind of had the idea that it was all
about general thinking
that you would be kind of reasoning with
logic and
sort of methods of reasoning about how
things should happen in the world
so you know if you want to study some
mechanical system you would reason about
how well when you push on a lever
one side goes down the other side goes
up and this happens and that happens
with pure philosophical style reasoning
okay so with wolfman alpha we didn't do
that
both from alpha uses mathematics it uses
physics
it's like you just turn that question
into a piece of mathematical physics and
then you just grind it
and you get to the answer and i remember
the folks who'd worked on some of these
sort of ai based reasoning question
answering systems
it's like this kind of isn't fair you
know we're working on it based on
reasoning based on sort of
philosophical type thinking you guys get
to cheat
and just use modern science the 300
years of development of modern science
to just jump to the answer so that was
an example of sort of the contrast
between
sort of philosophical style thinking and
modern science
mathematics style thinking i think that
the thing that i've realized in um
as i've worked on a lot of areas of of
science a lot of things that i've
figured out in science like
computational irreducibility
like a lot of things to do with
computational language design these are
essentially
questions that philosophers have talked
about
often for hundreds thousands of years
um it's very interesting to be able to
give sort of a scientific approach to
those questions
which makes them much more concrete you
can kind of ask a question you know what
is consciousness how does it work
well that's a you can argue about that
it's just a word what does the word mean
it means this to me that to you etc etc
etc but if you start saying what does it
mean
for for example the laws of physics you
you have an
anchor that allows you to start saying
something much more concrete
and allows you to sort of scientificize
that
that kind of discussion and that's been
some but but knowing
the sort of philosophical grounding
knowing kind of
the structure the strategy of what
you're trying to get to
that's something that philosophy gives
you and it's important for example i
happen to be right now working on the
question
of why does the universe exist which is
a
an interesting question that i think
we're actually going to be able to say
some things about
um and uh which i had not expected at
all i thought that was a question
i didn't even think that was a
philosophy question i thought that was a
theology question
i thought that was a question that
couldn't wouldn't even have
a thinking type foundation but it turns
out it looks like it does and you can
kind of understand it from a science
point of view
and it's pretty neat and hopefully i'll
have something to say about in a few
weeks
um but any case the the thing that um uh
you know that's a place where so so in a
sense philosophy
is pretty good at giving you the broad
outline of where are you trying to go
what's the structure what are you trying
to think through i don't think it's so
good
when it comes to very formal kinds of
things where you say
now let's lock in and just compute what
the answer is
philosophy doesn't really do that it
turns into maybe philosophical logic
goes more in that direction
but really that locks you know what you
have to go to something computational
you can represent you know the
philosophy gives you what are you trying
to figure out
you know free will versus determinism
what roughly is the question
you have to lock down that question more
precisely
using essentially more scientific ways
of thinking about things
and um and then you uh uh you kind of
can go um uh and that's kind of the
the arc of what happens but i think what
is for me very interesting is
um uh is going you know taking the
things one's understanding in science
and saying what does this mean for
questions and philosophy
and can one use the sort of outline of
ideas
that philosophy suggests to understand
how
uh things uh kind of fit together
in um uh and so how these sort of
conceptual blocks fit together
so i think that's you know understanding
that conceptual blocking is important
i think philosophy as a field uh
you know a lot of the ideas of
philosophy are terrific things for
people to think about at all sort of
stages because
they're things where everybody can have
an opinion about some question and
ethics or something
like that whereas in science you have to
know a lot of facts
to have a useful opinion so it's a good
place to sort of practice
thinking about things in general um and
i think that that's
uh um and you know i i think
if i were to say things that i've
thought about sometimes things i've
figured out
are sort of guided by philosophical
thinking but then to me
i don't really know that i know what i'm
talking about until i have a more sort
of structural computational scientific
approach i think sometimes in academic
philosophy today
there's you know it gets very elaborate
and it's very jargonized it's very much
you know talking about very much it's
i think you know i'm not sure that i
decode it very well
but it is a um uh you know a lot of
philosophy philosophy is a field
that where people are still referring to
aristotle and people are still
discussing aristotle
two thousand years later there are
fields like i don't know some areas of
biomedicine for example where
the paper's more than three years old
it's old news nobody's going to talk
about it
but in philosophy if it's 2000 years old
you're still talking about it
and i think in some ways that's a
healthy feature i didn't think that when
i was younger but i think
now in some ways that's a healthy
feature um because these things
you know until they get scientificized
they don't get solved
they're still things that are sort of
rattling around in the in the thinking
sphere so to speak
um but uh you know i think if i were to
ask about things i've worked on and
whether there
are flows from sort of philosophical
thinking i was talking about
sort of more academic philosophy i would
say that there's
for me the best philosophy that's
written about is philosophy
which the common person could perfectly
well understand
by the time the philosophy is is steeped
in science sounding
jargon but it's still philosophy i get
suspicious
because i think it is not as good a
system as good a formal system
as science or mathematical logic or
something like that is
it is a system that has a much fuzzier
way of deducing things
and i think sometimes the jargon is kind
of a
you know gives it the the veneer the
coating of something scientific
without having the raw sort of
horsepower of something scientific
inside
um so i tend to be more suspicious of
that but i think it's often
when it's sort of plain language and
it's pure
argument that can be explained in plain
language that can be quite powerful and
quite a good guiding force
for thinking about things in science all
right i'm being reminded
that i'm late for something so i think
it's it's time for me to wrap up here
and um uh i look forward to um
yeah uh encourage you to subscribe to
our channel
come again next week and
see you again then